ils enjoignent aux propose voyage sans
passeport
d'autres échanges nous voici à calcutta
où nous allons ensemble je crois visiter
le temps en tout cas voilà il nous
voyons une vache et nous voyons aussi un
des petits chevreaux aux oreilles de
cocker et on y bus qui emmène sacrifier
autant plus de qualités que nous verrons
tout à l'heure au cinéma y on s'arrête
que ce que fois la circulation les
autobus et taxis et personne ne vienne à
déranger
du côté belge on était jeunes ici tu
voulais bien tant aimé et robin cantal
en acier lobby sa femme à une équation
misère oui on dort dehors rouler dans
une couverture qui a plus de troubles
des tofs il ya une énorme mère l'a
beaucoup dit on vit dehors aussi j'en
suis si ces coûts fait très chaud c'est
chaud et humide à quelques tests un
climat et nive en table il le suit alors
se moderniser les charrettes à 2 puis
d'agents l'un des règles avec des feux
rouges et défaisaient mais si tout cela
avait la k-league a dû ce moment là
cette ville car c'est une ville d'art
discothèque et très exposition 19 cents
et keller aimable et on arrive à une des
plus terribles incarnation de caïx cali
la noire est donné son nom à calcutta
d'ailleurs parce qu'elle n'est descendu
et on sacrifie des chevrons mais goff
les cheveux
c'est un spectacle épouvantable qui plus
est à la ds
le sol est à niort puis est ramos et des
accusations de mardan c'est magnifique
et ceci était une femme du centre vous
voyez qui a de gros bracelets entrée
massive et des bagues aux doigts liens
du des camps de la région du billard les
dom
le che 10 s appelle ses parents ça c'est
du temple d'or
nous avons sauté de dinde en ghermani
c'est le temple d'or un temple
bouddhiste plutôt simple un monument
commémoratif ans et curieuse un oui
c'est l' architecture tout à fait
caractéristique de la thaïlande l'enfer
du scan
laissons le nom et la birmanie très
pointue avec des toits superposés voilà
un bon style va ou qui revient de son
encaissement sans parapluie
avant pourquoi il une main son parapluie
de l'autre un cabas line et les neuf
objets rituels qu'il a le droit de
posséder et le parapluie pourquoi dans
se protéger du soleil aux besoins se
dérober la vue des femmes
le bouddha recommandé d'équiper c'est
l'heure de la prière je pense c'est
toujours la prière on dépose beaucoup
soeur des fruits voilà des saints du
paradis bouddhiques et le bouddha au
bois doré laqué c'est une action grasse
perpétue sa direction grâce à péter
eckes mais ce n'est pas une divinité
reprise passe vous vient honorer la
mémoire d'un très gros sage et plutôt
une visite il n'en attend rien il nous
demande rien un orgue de soi-même
l'épuration de soi même là c'est un
marchand qui a été très astucieux il
vend une aux saintes dont on arrose le
bouddha et alors même la salle et
cuisine l'une et pomme d'arrosoir qui
rappelle probablement le bouddha dans sa
méditation temps soufflait la tempête et
que tomber des tonnes de cf
ici à bangkok donc non denses et encore
c'est encore un certain temps on trouve
encore des pouces mais voilà les pousse
à vélo de oui à deux places mais enfin
en berne en ait trois ou quatre
ah bon et on prend son bain en pleine
rue les femmes sont très fines seraient
celles et quand tu es dans ton petit
chignon qui est un peu perché sur le
coin de l'occiput très complète
on est une coquetterie elles sont
parfaites ravissant faisons je lis mais
les grandes avenues peu de véhicules et
tous les types de voitures que vous peut
imaginer immobilier brillante
carrosserie omis hausse identique
carrosserie date de 1905 l'audi 100 et
le marché aux fleurs pour honorer le
bouddha et il ne met pas de fleurs chez
eux uniquement pour le bouddha
uniquement pour lesquels mais pour
quelle raison voyez vous marchez vous
aussi vont suivre aussi le cigare
pourquoi mon équipe a lâché je ne vois
pas de raison en tout cas je n'en
connais pas remis la fleur est une
bénédiction du ciel on la vend les
divinités à ceux du fond sonore
nous voici maintenant un pas encore mais
voilà le marché le marché bon compte
le dire ce marché mais c'est un sampan
le marché qui se déroute sur des
kilomètres de canaux bangkok c'est la
venise de l'extrême asie il ya la grande
rivière mais nam et puis des cadeaux qui
en parle qui parcourt toute la ville et
marchons sociaux est ce que vous appelez
descente en mon sens pas me dire trois
planches ça va mais il sut ces trois
planches avec une fois mercredi en vie
et voilà le grand jeu de tous les gosses
asie le cerf-volant plein de qualités au
et voilà un futur ministre chef d'état
ou un marchand et on laisse les pandas
et très posture en lotus la marchande de
mani sky d epuis de do it up un câlin
occidentale d'ici
nice et andrée mallah nature cas les
petits cochons laquelle inaptes ou
tensions sont vives et nantes ou pas est
conservé dans ses eaux limoneuses eh
bien on ce bel on prend deux volets
social à tous elle n'est pas dangereuse
à tous que vous voyez ça sert à tout
c'est bien ce que je dis c'est donc je
pense qu'il doit y avoir une visibilité
acquise dès le premier âge où on résiste
et on en parle plus on n'en existe pas
et quand même aussi un oeil je crois que
c'est un peu ça la ne l'ont pas se voir
passer l'image du temple abritant le
bouddha d'émeraude
mais qu il n ya pas d mode je sais déjà
ce feu vert qui le palladium de du siam
et qui a été radié au laos en 16 cents
et quelques au cours d'une guerre qui a
coûté d'ailleurs très cher aux laotien
que parce qu'il les a pu leur pâle la
lionne mais aussi au roi qui était venu
chercher le bouddha l'a puni pour le
sang versé en rendant fou mon mieux
voilà les colombiens les canaux cet
hymne nuire et une impression de
grouillement amusé l'asie c'est cela
c'est lo green man c'est un énorme
nombre 35 ans là bas
oui c'est ça marchande de poisson tous
argent ni vissage instinet cette bonne
odeur de sumud poisson saumur est
regardé comme les enfants sont heureux
un chinois car le chinois est roi comme
commerçant la création et nous nous
retrouvons trouve qu'il ya quelque chose
à vendre avant
et dieu sait les choses qu'il peut y
avoir à vendre la barre de fabrication
locale ou importés de chine japon
malaisie
ils apprennent vite tous les asiatiques
ont sont adroits comme des comme des
poissons dans l'eau qui sont texan
double n'est pas une page et on les
jette à l'eau ils savent nager sans
complexe à la libye est libre le gardien
de nous sont terribles et débonnaire
regard des moyens très menaçant ce sont
des génies souper qui protège le temple
des mauvais esprits l'emploi le montant
peut en réalité quand on parle de
bouddha on ne devrait jamais employer ce
mot là ce sont des monuments
commémoratifs le type même du toit
siamois voilà le temple de l'or le down
qui est au bord de la maine âme très
très décoré ya pas un des six mètres
carrés qu'ils ne soient nourris et voilà
les génies qui le supportent père jimmy
bons et mauvais ont été asservis la fois
du brouillard
je travail énorme et nous voilà la
rizière judo fut d'ailleurs demandé à
payer c'est la rivière alors j'étais
moins bien awards d'autant que vous
envers parleriez jeanine poussé vent les
saisons jeu de récolte parle nous a
conduits il nous a conduits dans un coin
de mon corps au marché des fruits les
plus extraordinaires les plus inconnu
oui bon très bon un peu déconcerté trop
différents des nôtres à est différente
et saufs les bananes et encore ils ont
une trentaine de variétés de malheur
depuis des bananes bio 25 à 28 cm de
long 10 que des bananes qui ont cinq à
six centimètres et ce sont les plus
petits qui semble que ça vous revient
sûrement le marchand de soupe et le
marchand de boissons glacées le cuir
apsad la c1 fines poussières de glace il
va se suicider lien ci-dessus ainsi le
chinois marche en dessous celui-là est
installé en boutique il ya eu ma chance
ou ambulants qui transportent c'est la
ressentirai chaude en deux
vitrines et sebo sachs est très mauvaise
et délicieux c'est délicieux
je leur avais ces braves et une dignité
en arrêtant moins bien souvent dans la
rue pour acheter et manger de la soupe
chinoise
vous semblez ce désamour oui ce sont des
alliés
hommage à l'été maguette des sauces for
peace et vous ça vous manqué avec les
baguettes et j'ai essayé une 2 x m'a pas
trop trop trop mal réussi enfin j'avoue
ne suis pas cramé j'ai landes politesse
vous savez c'est de prendre avec ses
baguettes bon morceau d'un bol il de
mettre dans le bol du boisé c'est un an
et ce en voisin que avant les meilleurs
morceaux qu'on allait d'ensemble ici les
pussycat voilà une néo néo une mais où
ce sont des montagnards qui viennent du
rallye cette chouette c'est très curieux
ce sont des gens c'est une peuplade
qu'on dit venir de chaldée déjà traversé
toute l'asie pour venir jusque là sont
des montagnes arrive au dessus de 2000
et le mot mais on veut dire cha cha cha
voici quand même en compte
1 où il est il a l'air terrible et très
fin notre coin des temples de l'europe
de vous retrouver démotique à rappelle
étrangement ceux du cambodge
oui docteur bergeron merci infiniment de
nous avons à faire ce magnifique voyage
yann chagnaud vous a proposé voyage sans
passeport cette émission a été réalisée
avec le concours du docteur percheron et
le solange péters montage pierrelaye
sont à nick v discrit nathalie de muret
illustration sonore de nice blazer